let's go inside the castle cabin I'll
give you a little tour you start by
walking into the living room it's the
smallest of the three connected cabins
and here's another view let's go into
the second largest cabin here's our
first bathroom and the laundry room
whatevs and then look up yes
now we're up in the Loft it's such a
quiet and cozy little space look even
our railing has Moss of course let's go
back down through the living room past
the bookshelf and into the third largest
cabin which has our kitchen oh check out
these cool countertops they're old
bowling alleys and let's go outside on
the deck really quick look at all my
plants I love plants okay now let's go
upstairs into our bedroom yes
custom headboard by Jacob well
everything's pretty much custom in this
house even that vanity and here's our
second bathroom thanks for taking a tour
of our handmade Castle cabin here at
cabin land